hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in his essay the
challenge of cultural relativism one of
the key issues that James Rachel's is
going to examine is how in whether we
can in fact criticize or even condemn
the social or cultural practices
belonging to other groups or cultures
and the example that he uses in this
text is female genital mutilation which
there he calls excision a very
controversial social practice widely
condemned in the West but widely upheld
and practiced in other parts of the
world so we'll come back to that example
but you should think of many other
similar examples of things which in one
culture are considered not only okay but
actually the norm what you ought to do
and then are condemned with in many
other cultures and we could do this
thinking about times as well something
that was okay in the 1950s in one
culture may not be okay in the new
millennium in that same although I in
certain ways changed culture so the
central question here is
should we say that practices in other
cultures are wrong are morally wrong
should we say that they ought to be
criticized or condemned or perhaps even
prevented or in some way you know
minimized or if we do that
are we being imperialists are we going
against what cultural relativism would
tell us is okay now it's unavoidable
that in saying that something is wrong
period in any case we are imposing some
standards even if we're doing it just
within our own society and even if we're
doing it in the crudest way imaginable
where you say I have the authority
therefore I say this is wrong or I just
feel that it is wrong there's still a
standard it's not a very good standard
but it's some sort of standard so we're
always imposing some sort of standards
the question is whether were legitimate
whether we're doing something right or
valid in imposing those standards so if
cultural relativism is actually right
then one of its key doctrines would be
that what we're doing in imposing these
standards is we're merely imposing the
standards of our own culture upon
members of another culture and then that
would be viewed as illegitimate as in
some sense wrong now there's some
problems there of course from what
perspective are you saying that's wrong
Rachel doesn't worry so much about that
because he has a good alternate line of
attack for this sort of thing and he
says that this is the issue of asking
whether there are any culture
independent standards that we could
appeal to is there a culture independent
standard of right and wrong he has it as
a heading and all we really need is at
least one for cultural relativism
not be holding uniformly through there
to be some sort of weakness to it so
again he looks at this this practice of
female genital mutilation and you can go
to people in the countries and cultures
where it is practiced and say listen
over here we think that's wrong and we
considered barbaric but I want to hear
things from your point of view why why
do you think that not only this is okay
but this is actually required why why do
you view this as a good thing and people
will give you answers and the answers
that they will give you will not just be
simply well that's our culture right
that may be the initial starting point
in a discussion but when you probe a
little bit deeper it doesn't take too
long to do this if you're actually
talking with people from from another
culture they will start giving you all
sorts of other justifications so for
example when it comes to female genital
mutilation you know there's a number of
arguments are made in its defense women
who are incapable of sexual pleasure or
less likely to be promiscuous thus there
will be fewer unwanted pregnancies and
unmarried women more over wives for whom
sex is only a duty or less likely to
cheat on their husbands because they're
not thinking about sex they will be more
attentive to the needs of their husbands
and children husbands for their part
aside to enjoy sex with wives who have
been excised on excised women the men
feel are unclean and immature and rachel
says it would be easy and perhaps
arrogant to ridicule these arguments
notice an important feature of every one
of these arguments get past the the sort
of repugnance that we might feel in
hearing this and see what's actually
going on here those who are justifying a
practice in their own culture are
appealing to some sort of social
standards something that doesn't just
depend on well we've always done things
this way or this is our culture it could
be if we don't do it the gods are gonna
go after us that is a standard right it
may not be a particularly good standard
in the long run but it's still a
standard
the one that Rachel's brings up is that
on the whole people are better off
that's what the the view point is if
this particular practice is encouraged
and continued and people will
accordingly be worse off if this
practice is not continued if it's if
it's prevented now once things get to
that point of view you're no longer
talking about something that is just
from the perspective of that culture
because the fact that an outsider can
come in and ask hey why are you doing
this
this seems wrong and they say no no
you've you've got a mistaken viewpoint
on it it's actually right they're not
saying it's just right for them they're
saying this is right morally for human
beings you just be with people over
there you've got it wrong you're missing
out some some sort of important
consideration and this is the the
standard so if you then talk about the
these standards like for example does
the practice promote or hinder the
welfare of people affected by it this
becomes as he says an independent moral
standard that cultural relativism
forbids and he says it's a standard that
can be brought to bear in judging the
practices of any culture at any time
including our own so you know let's
consider this issue of female genital
mutilation right you could say too
though those people listen when we
examine the people who have undergone
this it seems that psychologically they
wind up being damaged by it you don't
want people to be psychologically
damaged that's not to their welfare is
it so you know maybe you should stop
doing that practice or genuine intimacy
can take all these different forms and
shapes and depriving somebody of you
know you might call the the organ of
their intimacy or a portion of that is
interfering with that that possibility
of something that could be happy
in isn't and wouldn't that be conducive
to people's welfare as well and we could
do this with any other controversial
social practice that's found in one
culture and not in another culture we
could we could make it depend on welfare
we could make it depend on notions of
Rights we could make it depend on all
sorts of other moral principles that
would straddle and run through different
cultures Rachel's then discussed as well
why are we reluctant then since we have
all sorts of standards available to us
why are we reluctant to condemn the
practices of other cultures he says
there's actually some good reasons not
completely good reasons not reasons that
would actually militate against ever
condemning another culture but somewhat
good reasons for being reluctant to
condemn practices one particularly for
people in the West but really this could
apply to any dominant culture there are
concerns about interference with others
social customs with their sets of norms
do we actually have the right to do so
as he points out Europeans and their
descendants in America do have a
shameful history of destroying native
cultures in the name of Christianity and
enlightenment in a sort of religious and
a secular philosophical social point of
view right so you know we might be
concerned about continuing that and he
says that that does make sense and so
some people refuse to criticize other
cultures but he says there's a
difference between two things one is
making a judgment saying this is
actually wrong this is morally wrong
another is acting upon that judgment and
saying therefore we're going to send in
the troops or regulate you with law or
impose some sort of economic sanctions
or
something along those lines and although
it may often you know be the case that
doing a does lead to B we do have to
recognize that they're not equivalent
and they're not identical so there's
nothing wrong with condemning something
that we actually think is wrong as a
matter of fact that's what they do in
other cultures but we have to be wary
about what level of other actions we're
going to have flow from that
condemnation or criticism another thing
that he talks about here is valuing
tolerance positively people may feel and
he says rightly enough that we should be
tolerant of other cultures tolerance is
no doubt a virtue a tolerant person can
live in peace with those who see things
differently it doesn't require saying
everybody's right but it does say it
doesn't require saying I'm gonna live
with you and not engage in conflict with
you but that doesn't mean that we need
to be tolerant of everything and as he
points out no culture is actually
completely tolerant they all have some
things that they say are off limits so
he says if we did not think some things
are better than others there would be
nothing for us to tolerate then the
final thing that he talks about our
concerns that we might be expressing
contempt for somebody's entire culture
in criticizing a particular practice and
he says this is just a mistake
unless we are intending to criticize the
entire culture by pointing at look at
look at what these people do right we're
not actually doing that he says to
condemn a particular practice is not to
say the culture on the whole is
contemptible as a matter of fact though
the culture could have many admirable
features and you might actually use
those Admiral feet admirable features in
order to make the case to people of that
culture that they should reconsider the
practice that they are engaging in so
long story short from Rachel's point of
view we actually can and should if we're
going to be moral beings condemned
practices in other cultures that we
think are immoral of course we should
apply the same standard to ourselves but
we do have a sort of apparatus here in
social standards or universal standards
that go beyond those of a mere culture
we have something in those to appeal to
across different cultures
you